багато років у газпромі є брав участь у
газових війнах на боці Росії без Путіна
ніяк я проголосував за Путіна щоб ви
розуміли ви стріляли по росіянах я робив
свою роботу для мене було важливо щоб Я
влучив туди куди стріляю щоб духу тут не
було будь-яких росіян розумієте до чого
дійшло дивом Я вижав загинув хлопець
який мене фактично закрив собою війна не
закінчиться миттєво ні сьогодні ні
завтра люди які прийдуть до влади
отримують колосальний важіль впливу і
торгівлі з заходом
уродженець України Ігор Волобуєв колись
працював у Москві віце-президентом
газпромбанку спочатку повномасштабного
вторгнення він повернувся на Батьківщину
і сьогодні у звані рядового служить на
фронті заради інтерв'ю в програмі в
тренді Волобуєв на кілька годин вирвався
до Києва і тут на кіностудії імені
Довженка розповів нам про те як ФСБ
контролює Газпром і Чому навіть після
відходу Путіна війна проти України
продовжиться
України продовжиться Ігорю Волобуєв
Ласкаво просимо до програми в тренді на
Deutsche Welle Дякую вам Костянтина що
запросили Добрий день в інтерв'ю які
видавали торік ще ви у цивільному одязі
не знаєте що на вас чекає ви служите
спочатку цього року Як я розумію у
збройних силах України як вам служиться
слухайте служу Я насправді вже понад рік
просто були різні формати моєї служби
служиться добре
Для мене було дуже важливим саме
потрапити до зони бойових дій і воювати
мені таку нагоду моє командування надало
Я був поранений
там така історія
дивом якщо щиро сказати я вижив але
загинув хлопець який мене фактично
закрив собою
двадцятирічний білорус
от
служу
багато добровольців не українців воюють
з вами
Я служу в інтернаціональному легіоні у
нас усі солдати - це громадяни не
України
тобто офіцерський склад - це українці за
паспортом
а решта це приблизно люди з 30 країн
у тому числі з країн Балтії з Литви
багато хлопців Яких Я особисто знаю які
тут воюють
росіяни які служать Вони служать окремо
Вони служать окремо там де я служу Я
єдиний росіянин у нас був один хлопець
Він виходить з Росії Він з росіянин і
Він загинув у квітні
тобто Наскільки я розумію вже
громадянство в нього було не російське і
Він загинув
а решта російських добровольців це як
називається російський добровольчий
корпус є Легіон Свобода Росії і є
російські добровольчий корпус А чим вони
відрізняються ви можете пояснити
ви знаєте для мене важливо не те чим
вони відрізняються що їх об'єднує
об'єднує їх
бажання у своїй країні Особисто я розсію
ніколи своєю країною не вважав тому що я
завжди знав що я українець і коріння моє
завжди було тут Хоча я проживу Москві 32
роки але народилися в Україні Я не
збираюся повертатися в Росію
а для них Важливо щоб Росія стала
цивілізованою демократичною країною
Я не хочу там і вони хочуть змінити там
Владу і повернутися туди про них дуже
різні чутки ходять Що це часто-густо
люди з дуже ультраправами переконаннями
російські добровольчий корпус не
приховує цього праві ідеї їхні
об'єднують просто як тема для бесіди як
же вони будуватиму демократію Якщо вони
такі от радикально праві це до них
запитання як Вони збираються будувати
Росію і яким бачать її майбутнє Я
особисто знайомий із керівництвом ердека
я
я ставлюся до того що вони робили на
фронті дуже позитивно А вони не
піар-проєкт вони реально щось роблять Ні
вони реальні хлопці які реально воюють і
вони були першими хто зайшов на
територію Росії зі зброєю в руках До
речі ви 30 років прожили в Росії хоч і
маєте українське коріння як сприйняли
товариші по службі Я знаю що ви
розмовляєте українською вільно проте як
вас сприйняли адже все ж таки у такій
ситуації 30 років прожитих у Москві Це
скоріше мінус для багатьох чи не так
звісно мінус бекграунд дуже впливає
особливо російський тут м'яко кажучи з
настороженістю ставляться до усіх
вихідців із Росії тим більше Зараз Якщо
раніше ще було поняття хороших росіян то
зараз дуже багато хто вже не розрізняє
людей знаєте багато хто
хочуть щоб духу тут не було будь-яких
росіян розумієте до чого дійшло вони
навіть не хочуть розбиратися гарний ти
чи поганий що там як А моя історія вона
загалом для України негативна тому що я
працював багато років у газпромі є брав
участь у газових війнах на боці Росії
тобто Моя історія вона дуже така
непроста
поставилися до мене дивіться в
особистому контакті У мене не було
жодного випадку коли б до мене хтось
ставився негативно агресивно
були моменти мене впізнавали на вулиці
коли про мене стало відомо вже більше
року минулого
люди підходили і запитували Чи це я я
казав так і мені тиснули руку тобто в
особистому контакті немає ви знаєте мені
багато українців з якими я спілкувався
усі практично які дізналися мою історію
від мене вони навіть жодного разу не
бачили не чули просто ми перетиналися і
вони дізнавалися хто я мені Практично
всі говорили одну річ а ми не знаємо як
би ми вчинили чи змогли б ми так як
зробили ви
вибрали участь у бойових діях ви
поранені вивели вогонь по противнику цей
противник якщо узагальнити це люди з
якими Ви пліч-о-пліч прожили 30 років
у вас не виникало жодних емоційних
переживань Я не знаю як краще сказати
якогось емоційного дисонансу можливо
Ви знаєте не виникало жодного разу
Тобто ви стріляли по росіянах я робив
свою роботу для мене було важливо і я
переймався Щоб те що я робив було
ефективно я думав про те щоб Я влучив
туди куди стріляю я займався вогневою
підтримкою це не контактний бій коли ви
бачите противника це дещо на відстані
ведеться вогонь
От і
для мене було важливо ефективно
відпрацювати
Ні у мене не було жодної моральної
дилеми проблеми
для мене це ворог тобто так само і я Для
них ворог якщо ми з ними Там
перетинаємося значить Вони хочуть мене
вбити
меня а я хочу щоб вони звідси пішли Мені
байдуже живими чи мертвими але щоб їх
тут не було бо це моя Батьківщина
наскільки
вистачить в українців просто фізичних
сил витримати цю російську агресію
Я розумію що ви скажете мені ви
військовослужбовець ви скажете що сил
Вистачить я це знаю
я для себе дізнався одну річ коли сюди
їхав по-перше я не знав і досі не знаю
чим усе закінчиться Я думаю ніхто не
знає чим усе закінчиться але для мене
було ухвалене рішення
я був би ясновидцем і 24 лютого знав що
це війна закінчиться не дуже добре для
України та українського народу
історія для України і Біблія
Рівненського народу насправді ціна яка
оплатиться зараз величезна вже зараз
я би все одно зробив те що зробив
тут вибір стоїть між відсутністю вибору
в українців немає вибору є дуже хороша
не приказка А українське гасло
як це російською девіз мабуть
Воля або смерть
Вибір є або ви живете у вільній країні і
платите за це величезну ціну
і ви в результаті перемагаєте
хліба або ж якщо ні ви йдете на смерть
Я дуже часто чую про Волю і свободу
України що це особлива цінність для
українців скажіть Ви 30 років прожили в
Росії для росіян Свобода не цінність
Я би дуже хотів щоб вона була цінністю
для будь-якої людини не важливо де вона
живе Я наведу вам приклад у 2012 році
коли Путін повертався до влади був такий
переможний мітинг як вони називали на
менежній площі
тоді була квота від газпрому
300 людей яких Газпром мав туди привести
цей мітинг був організований Це я знаю
точно
не можу сказати що всі 100%, але
більшість людей яких можна було там
побачити у вікнувши хроніку це люди яких
туди привезли квота від центрального
апарату газпрому складала 300 людей
готує момент я проголосував за Путіна
щоб ви розуміли цілком щиро не тому що я
працював у газпромі І не тому що мене
хтось змушував
але коли я почув що я повинен як
начальник управління на той момент
забезпечити якусь явку
я для себе вирішив що я сам не піду і
своїм співробітником скажу хочете ідіть
не хочете це ваш вибір від мене ви
жодних репресій не почуєте і Я готовий
за вас стояти стояти з вами якщо щось
таке відбудеться
Слава Богу департамент з інформаційної
політики газпрому тоді не залучили до
цієї акції але людей змушували казали що
будемо вас перевіряти переписувати
прийдете ви чи ні
розумієте про цінність Свободи я не хочу
сказати що у мене якесь особливе
ставлення до свободи але людина яка
чесно проголосувала за Путіна щиро Це
був я але коли я почув що мене туди
можуть погнати я для себе тоді ухвалив
рішення щоб не відбулося я не піду
цікаво що ви стверджуєте що голосували
за Путіна в 2012 році
ви вже бачили розгони мітингів були
перші ув'язнення
це не так як зараз Але тим не менш ви
все одно вважали що без Путіна ніяк я
вам скажу одну річ я чув ви багато разів
казали що вірили в це розумієте
от ви на болотну площу натякаєте
Для мене було одна площа минулого
практично непомітно
я багато разів намагався сам собі це
пояснити Я кажу річ яка мене зараз коли
я перебуваю в Україні дуже недобре
характеризує
я жив в якомусь іншому світі і я на те
щоб не займався політикою
але я щиро вважав тоді що Путін
нормальний президент
переоцінка моїх цінностей і внутрішня
еволюція сталася лише тоді коли
наступили на моє болюче рідне на Україну
Коли почався Майдан роль Росії
потім почалася війна
Крим потім Донбас тоді і я зрозумів що
мені брешуть до цього На жаль я був
жертвою такої ж пропаганди Як і всі
Как
ви говорили я жив в іншому світі от у
мене таке відчуття Я трохи попрацював у
корпоративному секторі у своєму житті
але до кінця Цей світ не зрозумів надто
коротко це було скажіть як жили колеги
довкола вас
Вони теж не помічали болотну площу Вони
теж потім не помічали майдан анексія
Криму вони всі кричали крім наш в якому
світі Вони живуть що Їх цікавить Скажімо
так очевидно ви людина з політичним
елементом а вони як живуть Розкажіть як
живе середній рівень можливо і вищий
рівень газпрому чим вони живуть
вище керівництво газпрому треба також
ділити бо є голова правління газпрому
Олексій Міллер
це особлива постать особливо наближена
до Путіна
Путін довіряє міллеру так як і раніше
він 23-й рік при владі в газпромі це
багато про що говорить
далі йдуть його заступники які звісно з
точки зору газпрому теж не божителі люди
які живуть в іншому світі з позиції
можливостей
люди які живуть в іншому світі з позиції
можливостей та впливу і матеріально це
зовсім не можна порівняти зі звичайним
обивателем і навіть зі співробітником
який працює у газпромі на середніх
позиціях
коли помітили Майдан точно помітили
Ось я вам кажу що Болотна площа для мене
пройшла пунктирно
У мене не було якихось розмов про
болотну Площу от Майдан це було постійно
але тут треба зважати на ту обставину що
всі знали що я не просто виходець з
України Я постійно в Україні бував я був
в Україні по 5 разів на рік і всі знали
до мене багато хто просто звертався
запитував що відбувається і от тоді коли
в мене відбулася ця переоцінка цінностей
я розповідав усім що те що відбувається
Це катастрофа це призведе до дуже
поганих наслідків і не можна це
підтримувати
анексію російську політику але при цьому
зрозумійте я про це говорив на
горизонтальному рівні
і ніде не бігав з українським прапором Я
не ходив на мітинги Я ходив лише на два
марші Миру організованих Борисом
Нємцовим у 2014 році проти війни на них
я був
я нікого там не закликав відкрито
цього мало розумієте в якусь миті 24
лютого сталося те що я вже не міг себе
нічим виправдати Якби я як і раніше
просто комусь пояснював ви знаєте Я
проти але при цьому продовжував жити і
працювати на них
російська економіка під санкціями
Вот как они будут які вони будуть
ухвалювати рішення щоб викрутитися з
цього
адже це серйозна криза це не газові
війни з Україною це реально стосується
всієї російської економіки і стійкості
режиму
Опишіть як вони ухвалюють рішення який
тип мислення у них
між людьми які ухвалюють рішення в Росії
і тими які потім живуть з цими рішеннями
величезна Прірва
для людей які ухвалюють рішення і
входять у вище ешелони влади мало що
змінилося з точки зору їхнього побуту
життя
вони як жили Товстому шарі шоколаду так
І продовжують жити як мали величезну
владу Так і досі мають і вплив і владу
можливості гроші не
буває люди які молодші нижчі на сходинку
дві
вони дивляться ці динозаври можуть ще
років 20 сидіти
вони не хочуть вирватися не хочуть
підірвати систему вони згодні що буде
завжди так
візьмімо рівень того ж заступника голови
правління газпрому чи членів правління
газпрому це дуже високий рівень не
співстав незміллером він стоїть десь на
небі
багато хто з них десятки років уже
служать міллеру в його команді
це люди які пустилися берега
я вам більше скажу про Газпром
верхівка точно знала Міллер знав що 24
лютого Минулого року почнеться війна
Бо плани які були у російської армії це
стрімке просування а для Путіна в той
час усе пов'язане з експортом газпрому а
через територію України йдуть експортні
газогони Це був основний фетиш
Вони знали що почнеться війна бо треба
було міняти працівників на
газорозподільчих компресорних станціях
тобто вони думали що коли захоплюють усе
вони мали одразу ж забезпечити
управління газотранспортною системою
України тому я не маю жодних сумнівів що
Міллер знав що почнеться 24 лютого
так от Хто ці люди
Це точно не середній клас російський це
високий рівень з точки зору впливу
матеріального забезпечення і життя
Я наведу кілька прикладів життя нехай
глядач сам робить висновки
член правління газпрому збиває на смерть
перебуваючи за кермом свого автомобіля
людину
це факт Просто ніхто не знає його
відмазує людина яка є куратором від ФСБ
у кожній великій державній компанії з
Державної участю в Росії є така людина
із ФСБ Зазвичай це чинний Генерала ФСБ
ці люди вони в одній зв'язці
[музика]
дивіться Вони мають що втрачати
не треба забувати про Компромат Мені
особисто одного разу Андрій Акімов
голова газпромбанку сказав що на всіх
нас є компромат
ці всі історії лягають у папочку
розумієте тобто папочка - це реальність
вона існує на всіх Вона лежить у Путіна
я не знаю де вона лежить але дивіться у
газпромі газпромбанку є наглядачі з ФСБ
усі керівники служби газпромі це
називається корпоративним захистом або
службою безпеки це все вихідці з ФСБ
і не Міллер призначають цих людей їх
призначають у ФСБ Путіна або приберуть
або він помре і після цього всіх хто
залишиться скажуть Ми повинні продовжити
велику справу Володимира Володимировича
і продовжити цю війну так дивіться
Припустимо що Путін сьогодні помирає не
важливо як його більше фізично не існує
війна не закінчиться миттєво Ані
сьогодні Ані завтра люди котрі прийдуть
до влади ми їх не знаємо Не важливо хто
отримують колосальні важіль впливу і
торгівлі заходом так вони хотітимуть
закінчити цю війну але вони будуть
прагнути продати її якомога дорожче
Ігорю Волобуєв дуже Дякую і вам дуже
дякую